pour bien des gens quand on parle des
scandale cinar montauriol nord sûr on
pense à des stratagèmes compliqué des
montages qui sont bien aussi noté mais
pour les citoyens ordinaires qui se sont
fait arnaquer dans ces scandales
c'est très complet prix en panique j'ai
perdu mon argent à l'état de tout
l'argent qu'elle était de montréal des
centaines de millions de dollars ont
disparu
et depuis vingt ans ils sont nombreux à
chercher les cachettes des acteurs de
ces fraudes
moi j'étais le chat et ces gens là
étaient des souris finalement c'était
une chance on a du nouveau on a trouvé
une nouvelle piste pour trouver l'argent
et on est ali confronté à un homme qui
est au coeur de tout ça et qui n'a
jamais paru du pays bas pour penser que
j'ai 5 millions de dollars franchement
votre question est insultante ici marie
maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
à son retour de voyage dans les caraïbes
en 2011 le fondateur du studio
d'animation cinar waynberg a droit à
tout un comité d'accueil à l'aéroport
trudeau
l'entrepreneur auparavant louangé par
les milieux culturels et financiers se
retrouvent escortés menottes aux
poignets devant les caméras quelques
jours plus tard johnny zoumboulakis le
président de norshield un fonds
d'investissement vanté par les médias
est lui aussi arrêté
lino matteo le dirigeant de la société
d'investissement en marbre où il subit
le même sort
ils sont accusés de fraude c'est l'une
des fraudes des plus importantes de
l'année dans l'histoire du canada
moniteur de ce pays lors du plus long
procès devant jury
l'histoire canadienne ces trois
individus ont fait face à la justice
mais où sont passés les centaines de
millions de dollars des investisseurs
floués
le piste dans une fuite de documents
secrets nous mène vers l'île de man est
un stratagème confidentiel pour cacher
des fortunes à l'abri des créanciers
depuis plus de 15 ans cette enseignante
à la retraite de la banlieue de montréal
traverse de bien dure épreuve
catherine rich dans nos villes son mari
jean-claude ont perdu 500 mille dollars
les fonds qu'ils avaient soigneusement
économiser pour assurer leurs vieux
jours
ces dossiers remplis de douloureux
souvenirs représente des années de lutte
acharnée pour retrouver leur argent et
pour obtenir justice
ç'a changé nos vies on était proche de
la retraite on travaillait toujours là
on a dû continuer de travailler
11-12 anges j'ai pris ma retraite ya
cinq ans mon mari travaille encore de
temps en temps à la fin des années 90
leur planificateur financier leur avait
conseillé d'investir dans des fonds
gérés par les sociétés montréalaises
norshield immense oui aux déplacements
apparemment sûrs et offrant de bons
rendements
selon le planificateur nos placements
étaient garantis
il ne montrait aussi que des
firme comptable chez eux vérifiez des
états financiers
il y avait des articles dans le journal
qui disait comment certaines d accueil
et d
innovateur justement à créer ces fonds
la droite sont tout comme catherine rich
d'un autre elle aussi placer toutes ses
économies
soixante cinq mille dollars en tout dans
les fondements fuyant c'était dans
montréal c'est pour mon retrait dans le
futur d'avoir parce que je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas pas une pension avec le mont
compagnie j'ai travaillé je sur
commissions et dans le cas de demande
vous êtes obligés d'investir un minimum
de 50 milles et pour cette raison le
prix par deux les personnes les
investisseurs sont les personnes plus
âgées
ces femmes à l'aube de la retraite
n'avait aucune idée que leur économie
de même que celle de milliers d'autres
petits investisseurs canadiens allaient
s'engouffrer dans un stratagème
d'investissement frauduleux un
stratagème mis en place par les
montréalais lino matteo et john's wood a
kiss des habits de longue date
il s'agissait en réalité d'un système
pyramidal où les revenus ne provenaient
pas d'investissement dans le marché
financier mais plutôt des fonds fournis
par de nouveaux investisseurs selon la
procureure à la retraite céline bilodeau
c'était un stratagème à la ponzi
monsieur un truc à qui ce monsieur
matteo il plaçait pas large
donc il y avait pas livré un intérêt il
n'y avait pas des vrais revenus
les petits investisseurs n'ont pas été
les seuls à se faire berner et ville de
sherbrooke laval et saguenay et ont
placé une part des caisses de retraite
de leurs employés
même des fonds provenant du célèbre
studio d'animation cinar ont été
investis dans cette combine par son pdg
one on one bugs mais à l'issue de ses
actionnaires
fondée par le couple nolwenn burg et
micheline charest cinar compte à son
apogée des centaines d'employés qui
produisent entre autres les populaire
dessin animé cailloux vie arthur c'est
tel déni du nord c'était famille c'est
morial c'est un des joyaux de montréal
durant les années 90 le chelem et brawn
étaient les gens importants dans
l'industrie canadienne et c'était très
bien connu très bien respectée
le coupé très bien branché dans la
sphère politique et contribue
régulièrement à la caisse du parti
libéral fédéral avec la valeur de ses
actions en hausse
cinar devient la coqueluche des marchés
financiers la société hamas plus de 150
millions de dollars américains lors
d'une émission publique actions des
fonds récoltés pour l'expansion de ses
activités mais en scrutant les états
financiers des vérificateurs découvre
qu'une grande part des sommes amassées
avait été transféré à l'extérieur du
pays sans l'autorisation du conseil
d'administration et des actionnaires
wainberg et son directeur financier
avait placé en secret 120 millions de
dollars américains aux bahamas dans des
sociétés liées à l'enrichir de m'ennuyer
des sociétés dirigées depuis montréal
par lino matteo et johnson duda kiss
alors pourquoi les bahamas
on s'est rendu compte que monsieur en
dessous de caisse au frais comme un
service clé en main vous pouviez jouer
dans vos états financiers et ça leur
permettait de cacher d'argent au fisc et
au lieu de placer l'argent non des fonds
d'investissement sur tel que promis aux
investisseurs de cinar dans un
prospectus
ces sommes se sont retrouvés dans les
stratagèmes douteuses de norshield et
demande rio ce qui était particulier
c'est dans le prospectus on disait que
l'argent devait être bien placé que ce
soit sécuritaire l'investisseur avait
été trompée en investissant chez snarr
en février 2000 le conseil
d'administration de cinar apprend avec
stupeur les résultats de l' enquête des
vérificateurs les administrateurs de
cinar demande à l'avocat montréalais de
bois ne se rendre sur place aux bahamas
afin de tirer les choses au clair c'est
maintenant que pendant nos travaux pour
récupérer l'argent ils ont travaillé
pour cacher leurs gens et pour cacher la
vérité parce que moi j'étais le chat et
ces gens là étaient des souris et
finalement c'était une chasse
cette chasse commence des coupures
drogue arrive aux bahamas des exécutants
norshield déguerpissent vers la floride
et se réunissent en secret dans un hôtel
de miami beach flag est débout vraiment
à côté d'eux des bahamas été poussé
assez loin pour être à l'abri des des
avocats alors qu'ils leur poursuivaient
mais il était caché dans une chambre
d'hôtel trois ou quatre personnes à
fabriquer des fausses et aux financiers
sont mis à fabriquer des faux documents
pour démontrer à cinar que l'argent est
bien placé ce qui était absolument faux
qui ont fait ça tellement vite qu'ils
sont trompés même des dates qu'on a pu
les corroborer parce qu'on a trouvé un
fat un fax qui a été envoyé de cet hôtel
lyon quand et où de faire croire à cinar
et le conseil d'administration que tout
était catholique que tout était légitime
alors que artiste est complètement faux
c'est fabrication de faux documents en
floride s'est effectuée sous les
directives de lino matteo qui était au
téléphone à montréal
avec nos collègues du fift et nous avons
invité lino matteo à répondre à nos
questions c'est la première entrevue
qu'il accorde aux médias depuis le début
de cette affaire il clame encore
aujourd'hui son innocence deepak a pas
eu fraude
mais si on considère que mon rôle était
de préparer des documents
à mon avis il y avait pas d'intention de
frauder est ce que je comprends c'est
que s'il n'y a pas d'intention de fraude
et le pot de crime
au début du mois de mars 2000
c'est le mutisme complet chez cinar
personnes le comptable à san pédro et
congédier les fondateurs van weynbergh
et micheline charest démissionnent de
leurs postes de direction les
vérificateurs découvre que le couple
utiliser l'argent de cinar à des fins
personnelles un piano de 23 mille
dollars
les rénovations de leur résidence de
westmount et de magog les salaire de la
nounou et du paysagiste tout ça sur le
bras de l'entreprise
c'était complètement complètement
inappropriée temps c'est inapproprié
dans une compagnie privée mais c'est
même plus à propos inappropriés dans une
compagnie pas blake ils ont utilisé ces
notes comme finalement leur banque
de plus renault avait secrètement accès
à une marge de crédit sur les 120
millions de dollars qu'il avait envoyé
sans autorisation aux bahamas
donc ça leur permettait eux d'utiliser
cet argent là pour s'enrichir on sait
que et ça toute cette marge de crédit
cela n'apparaissait évidemment pas dans
les états financiers
pendant que l'univers de world wine bar
gay de micheline charest s'effondre le
conseil d'administration réclame que nos
chiots en bourse l'argent de cinar qui
avait été envoyé aux bahamas sans
autorisation baroud et b ils ont dit pas
de problème on va retourner l'argent on
va trouver l'argent obtenu sur des
montants mais moment donné ils ont
arrêté leurs paiements
c'était apparent que c'était une fraude
pour nous et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
est devenu le chef prend les grands
moyens en décembre 2001 il provoque la
liquidation de la société de norshield
où devait se trouver l'argent mais
syndic de faillite se rend compte que ce
n'est plus qu'une coquille vide
l'argent a été transférée vers d'autres
paradis fiscaux selon un plan conçu par
lino matteo web
le syndic va chercher tout ce qu'il peut
ok c'est normal de se protéger du syndic
si c'était vos avoirs vous aussi vous
auriez intérêt à les protéger
et il sait que je suis à la chasse
il sait qu suite est déterminé il veut
il veut trouver des idées des façons de
meyreuil ralentir il devient lui aussi
la cible des avocats de syna mais ses
déboires prennent un virage dramatique
en 2004 son épouse micheline charest
meurt à l'âge de 51 ans à la suite d'une
opération de chirurgie esthétique
malgré ses démêlés avec cynar warner
continue de fréquenter la route société
montréalaise
il assiste en 2005 au mariage le plus
médiatisé de l'année avec sa nouvelle
conjointe pendant que les nombreux
rebondissements dans l'affairé cinar
font les manchettes le doute s'installe
pour bon nombre d'investisseurs de nos
chiffres démentent juillet quand j'ai lu
aussi au sujet de silence a pris comme
un autre tournure comme si c'était
illégal ou s'était pas correct c'est
fond de l'eau puis nous mais nous aussi
on a été un best investi dans nos
archives j'ai téléphoné à mon
planificateur quand j'ai écouté le
nouvelle de sénart est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose de seniors qui affecte
chaussures en cuir
on en a dit non tout écart est séparée
inquiète
janet watson se rend à l'adresse de
maintenir la montréal et là tout un choc
lorsqu'elle aperçoit pour la première
fois le siège social du fonds
d'investissement de lino matteo
j'ai pris cette photo en compagnie de
130 millions wii avec un adresse l'un
des leurs dans une double aix puis au
cours de l'été 2005 leurs pires craintes
se confirment
toutes les sociétés liés à norshield et
m'enfuir sont elles aussi mises en
liquidation qui c'est un château de
cartes finalement partis souvent dation
des mensonges quand sir car c'est les
châteaux qui tombe
au retour même la mafia s'est fait
flouer et réclame son argent avec des
méthodes percutante
[Musique]
si vous avez vu film mafia inc que vous
avez certainement pas oublier cette
scène très violente d'ailleurs ou des
mafieux vont passer à tabac un financier
dans une belle tour à bureaux du
centre-ville
et bien cette scène elle est inspirée
d'une histoire vraie le scandale
financier norshield
lorsque catherine mi temps on se rend
compte que toutes ses économies se sont
volatilisés dans l'effondrement de nos
chine en truites le désespoir une envie
c'était incroyable on était bouleversé
c'était une sorte de deux sources de
stress épouvantable
j'étais fâché avec moi même nom comment
j'aurais pu faire ça jenny watson elle
reçoit ce message alarmant de son
conseiller financier
[Musique]
j'étais en panique
au début je crois pas que ça s'est passé
mais
éventuellement j'ai eu elysées que oui
il ya un problème j'ai perdu mon argent
j'ai pas de tout l'argent qui était
demeuré abl après le choc initial
catherine rich gannon se ressaisit et
tente par tous les moyens d'obtenir de
l'aide afin de retrouver l'argent perdu
je me suis dit il faut essayer de faire
des plaintes
il faut faire de quoi je suis allé en
mode action
je ne voulais pas atteint dcti elle
contacte l'autorité des marchés
financiers l'homme goodman canadien
l'association des courtiers
partout elles essuient des refus même la
grc ne veut pas faire enquête
j'ai appris un agent de la grc il
m'avait dit madame c'est trop compliqué
c'est trop complexe et on n'a pas de
personnel pour faire un accueil
[Musique]
en 2006 catherine rich gannon se rend
cet hôtel de dorval
une importante réunion plus de 600
investisseurs en colère convoque le pdg
de man pluie lino matteo et lui de
membres de leur rende des comptes
janet watson assiste aussi à l'assemblée
il a reçu beaucoup de commentaires des
victimes il ya des personnes qui qui a
dit line hausse
où est notre argent la salle était
pleine de victimes et j'ai regardé des
autres personnes qui a le même âge que
moi ou plus âgées chez dybex incroyable
que toutes les personnes ici sont dans
le même bateau que moi sauf la gauche je
suis allé à cette réunion
et j'ai répondu aux questions ça a été
une des pires journées de ma vie
conspué par la foule lino matteo nie
avoir caché des fonds dans les paradis
fiscaux et s'offusque lorsqu'un
investisseur lui demande si manche où il
est en fait une fraude pyramidale
j'ai beaucoup d'empathie pour les
investisseurs qui ont perdu de l'argent
mais c'est dommage qu'il n'y comprennent
pas grand chose c'est la première fois
que je veux dire ça en public
personne n'a perdu autant d'argent
points c'est une sociopathe et il n'a
pas de responsabilité dans tout ça c'est
la faute du gouvernement parce qu'ils
ont fermé sa compagne et
pas de remords envers les victimes
il n'y a pas que les petits
investisseurs qui sont en colère des
proches du clan rizutto qui dirige alors
la mafia montréalaise haut placé des
millions $ banshee et réclament leur
argent immédiatement quand on a des
personnes à rembourser la dent des
faillites
on a les institutions bancaires on a
crime organisé puis on a les
investisseurs individuels mais qui vous
allez remettre l'argent premier
au 21ème étage la place ville-marie à
montréal en novembre 2005 des membres de
la mafia débarque à l'improviste pour
lancer un ultimatum à john dowd a kiss
nos dirigeants de norshield
la violente confrontation a inspiré une
scène du long métrage mafia inc
sur ce transfert la cache mal un soutien
dans l'heure suivante un des chefs du
clan rizutto francesco del balso a joint
au téléphone vincenzo cassola un ancien
partenaire de johnson duda keith leurs
conversations été intercepté par des
policiers dans le cadre du projet
colisée sur le crime organisé
voici un extrait de cet appel
deux heures d'attenté nous avons fait
entendre l'enregistrement à lino matteo
chose
donc j'ai pas de commentaire n a game 2
6 2 6 2 6 qui sont du pipeau
il ya des gens qui veulent me battre et
après j'étais pas impliqué là dedans il
y en a qui ont perdu la tête
des fois il ya des six qui essaient
d'avoir l'air grand ou
[Musique]
en 2006 les avocats de sina tente de
mettre la main sur les actifs de
wannenburg dans ses résidences de wes
menthe et magog
il découvre d'étranges prêt hypothécaire
sur ses propriétés
[Musique]
les prêts hypothécaires sont liées à une
obscure banque privée des bahamas la
barre hinton ben qu'est nichée dans un
des bureaux de cet immeuble de nassau
selon son site web aujourd'hui disparu
elle offre à une petite clientèle triée
sur le volet des services financiers sur
mesure y compris la protection contre
d'éventuelles créanciers et tout ça dans
la plus grande discrétion la période in
time qu'il est dirigé par le canadien
michael morris voici la seule photo que
nous avons trouvés sur son ancien site
web personnel une photo intitulée mon
bureau c'était pas clair vraiment
c'était quoi bernard bec
c'était pendant qu'on ne connaît fait
mais nous avons vu que effectivement il
ya eu des transferts des comptes
les avocats de cinar tendent un piège
aux banquiers dwyane wade dans l'espoir
de faire la lumière sur ces comptes du
bahamas
ils prennent rendez vous avec michael
morris sous un faux prétexte
dans un café starbucks profitant de son
passage à toronto
lui si il lui remet une assignation à
comparaître l'obligeant se soumettre à
un interrogatoire mais un juge de cour
supérieure du québec a rejeté cette
assignation à comparaître en raison du
subterfuge employés par les avocats de
cinar moi je voulais utiliser tous les
utiles qui étaient disponibles afin
d'avoir la vérité d'avoir l'information
pour mes clients
nous avons essayé quelque chose qui
n'était pas habituel j'avoue mais
c'était au moins légales en ontario nous
avons cette obligation de tout essayer
malheureusement on n'a pas eu accès à
monsieur maurice c'est dommage mais on à
vis avec ça devant l'impasse les avocats
abandonne cette piste bergame sous
serment avoir plus qu'une vingtaine de
millions de dollars en tout est conclu
une entente à l'amiable avec des avocats
de cinar satisfait sous les génois de
parler d'eux
règlement mais je suis prêt de consommer
que nous avons entendre en principe en
fin de compte cinar parvient à récupérer
une large part des sommes placées sans
autorisation dans nos archives de
m'enfuir mais pour les centaines de
petits investisseurs qui avaient placé
leurs économies dans les mêmes fonds
d'investissement c'est une toute autre
histoire
malheureusement pour moi j'ai su que
l'argent qu'on avait investi en or
gilles allais pour payer justement
remettre l'argent hasina ou remettre
l'argent la banque royale du canada
1 c'est toujours le petit investisseur
qui en dernier après le paniquer le foot
station le cola a commencé est sa seule
raison que j'ai travaillé depuis 15 ans
pour avoir justice janet watson devient
la porte parole des 1600 victimes
demandent rio elle se rend à ottawa pour
inciter le parlement à resserrer les
lois sur la criminalité financière
j'ai rencontré mr peur j'ai rencontré
monsieur magna cherchait un contre et
messieurs les temps pour changer les
lois pour pousser pour les les sentences
plus sévères
puis en 2011 les suspects dans l'affairé
cinar ont finalement été arrêté à
l'issue d'une longue enquête menée par
la sûreté du québec en croit cette
criminelle les attend une lueur d'espoir
pour les victimes
où est passé l'argent
vingt ans après le début de ce scandale
on a une nouvelle piste d'une opacité
parfaite loin des regards indiscrets
[Musique]
wang wang bing et lino matteo ont subi
leur procès ils ont d'ailleurs été
reconnue coupable mais ça fait des
années que plusieurs pensent qu'il ya
encore de l'argent caché quelque part
eh bien on a trouvé une nouvelle piste
qui pourrait nous mener vers le butin
des fraudes procès cinar le fondateur de
la maison de production
ronald weinberg et c'est que deux autres
hommes d'affaires sont accusés d'avoir
orchestré une vaste fraude de 120
millions de dollars
burg s'est ouvert ce matin au palais de
justice de montréal 17 ans après les
premiers faits aller
moi je prenne un autobus de la rue sur
des mobiles
et je marchais pendant 40 minutes le
pommeau rendu au palais de justice
beau temps mauvais temps
alors que s'ouvre le procès criminel
dans la sphère cinar en 2014
4 et janet watson se font le devoir
d'être sur place
le plus souvent possible on représentait
les victimes parce que ce qu'on voit les
victimes ceux des noms et des numéros
mais on est des vrais personnes les
procureurs de la couronne matthew
ferguson et céline bilodeau décortique
avec des experts des milliers de
transactions financières caché derrière
une myriade de sociétés écrans et ça
c'est là l'organigramme de norshield
on voit très bien comment ces complexes
c'est juste prix le matériau qui
comprend ça notre mission première c'est
de vulgariser se rassurer le jury qui
n'avait pas besoin d'être des comptables
dd oui en finance il avait juste besoin
de comprendre c'était quoi la madone et
éthique et qui était responsable ultime
en des transactions
pendant déroulement du procès one on one
bull s'envole régulièrement vers le
panama
entre le moment de son arrestation et la
fin du procès il effectue 17 voyage et y
séjourne 512 jours en tout lui avait le
droit de de s'envoler de son père dit
avec bois de quitter le pays pendant des
mois avec son passeport
je pense chaque web
le procès dure plus de deux ans il
s'agit du plus long procès devant jury
de l'histoire canadienne
le verdict est finalement tombé dans la
sphère cinar
les trois accusés sont reconnus
coupables de la majorité des 29
accusations de fraude
lino matteo soutient aujourd'hui qu'il a
été injustement condamné et prétend que
le juge a erré dans ses directives au
jury
dow jones le juge à mon avis est un
homme intelligent d'accord mais il
n'avait aucune expérience dans le
domaine des affaires
il s'y fie aux témoins et comme je lui
ai fait remarquer ces témoins avec lino
matteo et john antonakis pick up d'une
peine de huit ans wahlberg et condamné
lui à neuf ans de prison mais je me suis
dit quoi que soit le temps qui passe en
prison là c'est leur peine non ça ne
compensera pas la perte de toutes les
époques en dépit de toutes les enquêtes
et les procès une grande part des fonds
placés par les investisseurs restent
introuvables
plus de 400 millions de dollars n'ont
jamais été retrouvés il ya d'argent que
jamais qu'on n'a jamais retrouvé
pensez vous que les principaux
intéressés ont mis de l'argent de côté
moi ma théorie c'est que quand vous êtes
assez intelligent pour échafauder des
stratagèmes comme ça pour fodé il ya de
bonnes chances que vous ayez pu en
mettre de côté où sont passés les
centaines de millions de dollars disparu
nous avons trouvé des indices qui nous
mène de l'autre côté de l'atlantique à
l'île de man un paradis fiscal situé
entre l'irlande et l'angleterre
ces anciennes forteresses ont longtemps
protéger l'île de man contre les
envahisseurs
aujourd'hui on y trouve une prospère
industrie de services financiers
elle multitude de cabinet offre des
services de gestion de fortune à des
clients du monde entier dans la plus
grande discrétion
en fouillant le registre des entreprises
de l'est demain nous avons trouvé une
nouvelle piste qui semble lié à l'argent
volé nous avons découvert quatre
sociétés portant des noms d'armes
anciennes qatar ces axes ce pata et
cherche quoi
ces sociétés sont liées à des canadiens
dont l'identité n'a paraît pas dans les
documents publics
ces quatre sociétés ont été incorporés
en décembre 2001 la même semaine
lino matteo et john's wood a kiss
ordonné transfert de millions de dollars
d'oenologie aux vers des paradis fiscaux
dans le but de fuir leurs créanciers
trois de ces sociétés ont été dissoutes
au moment où la fraude a été révélée au
grand jour en 2005 nous avons montré ces
documents ouest morice un des avocats
mandatés pour retrouver les fonds de
cinar
la professeure en droit fiscal et des
buts et du plq marwari ce qu'ils croient
aussi que ces sociétés sont probablement
liés à la faute de cinar et de chiots
moi je ne crois pas aux coïncidences je
crois beaucoup plus à au travail pour la
préparation puis si il était clairement
préparé
john xanthoudakis nie avoir connaissance
de ces sociétés et nino matteo aussi dit
ne rien savoir au sujet des sociétés
l'île de man afin de cet étranger jamais
entendu parler
nous avons découvert un autre indice
dans les documents officiels de shh quoi
la quatrième société écran on y trouve
le nom de michael morris le banquier de
ron wayne bugs lorsqu'il est interrogé
en 2006 par les avocats de cinar ronald
weinberg admet grands comptes a été mis
sur pied pour lui par michael morris
il avoue que ce compte n'est pas à son
nom mais qu'il en est le bénéficiaire
il dit ignorer à quel nom est
enregistrée le compte
il affirme n'avoir aucun contrôle sur ce
compte et prétend n'avoir reçu aucun
document ou relevés bancaires seraient
personne de normalement constitué qui va
transférer des millions de dollars sans
recevoir aucun écrit aucune confirmation
écrite aucun relevé barca wallon
wahlberg a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue et dit n'avoir aucun lien
avec les sociétés de lille demain mais
nous avons découvert un autre indice
pour canada
nous avons appris que wang bing est dans
la ligne de mire du fisc
l' agence du revenu du canada réclame
qu'il paie des pénalités pour avoir omis
de déclarer des millions de dollars dans
des comptes bancaires à l'étranger des
révélations étonnantes pour l'avocat
billy bragg qui était à ses trousses
homme surprend oui
mais ça me surprend ouais ouais ouais
parce qu'on est posé des questions on a
fait enquête et finalement on n'a jamais
s'était jamais jamais jamais divulguer
l'existence cet argent mat
dans sa réponse aux autorités fiscales
ou halloween burke soutien qu'ils
n'étaient pas tenus de déclarer cet
argent car les comptes à l'étranger
n'était pas à son nom l' agence du
revenu lui a transmis le 21 septembre
2016 un projet de cotisation pour les
montants réclamés exactement le même
jour à l'île de man des procédures pour
liquider la société cherche quoi ont été
enclenchées alors c'est pas des
coïncidences
à ce moment là elles aussi tout à coup
comme par magie elle disparaît après la
pause on confronte lino matteo qui
n'aime pas beaucoup nos questions on
arrête ça arrêter les caméras vous avez
le choix vous arrêtez les caméras et on
se parle de minutes où je m'en vais
[Musique]
depuis quelques années on a un peu plus
de lumière et transparence grâce à ses
grandes fuites de données comme le
panama papers les périodes des spurs et
quelle ne fut pas notre surprise
lorsqu'on a trouvé une piste qui semble
relier deux histoire troublante et de
façon complètement inattendu kpmg et
cinar 4 mystérieuse société écran créer
à lille demande pourrait être la clé
pour trouver les millions de dollars
disparu dans scandale cinar
nos chiffres démentent lyon
qui a pu aider à les mettre sur pied à
ottawa en 2016 le comité des finances de
la chambre des communes s'est intéressée
à l'île de man et plus particulièrement
à un stratagème controversée mise au
point par le cabinet comptable kpmg
selon ce stratagème les riches clients
de kpmg donnaient leur fortune à une
société écran de l'île de man
administrés par des prête-noms
c'est un plan qui est à faire aux
multimillionnaires et milliards da pour
se protéger de l'impôt de façon purement
juridique ou une dette n'est pas de
façon officielle ces actifs l'homme et
il vous appartient de canmet témoigner
devant le comité des finances
un dirigeant kpmg a soutenu que le
stratagème respectait les règles de
l'époque mais qu'un tel système était
devenu indéfendable
le comité des finances a obtenu ce
document interne de kpmg ou le cabinet
comptable assurer ses clients que leur
fortune serait bien protégés impossible
pour des créanciers ou même des
ex-conjoints de réclamer quoi que ce
soit pour avoir accès à ce stratagème
confidentielles les clients devaient
payer kpmg au moins cent mille dollars
tout ça évidemment c'est pas que nous du
grand public c'est pas connu évidemment
du fisc et encore moins des créanciers
auxquels on veut se cacher et c'est
purement au fond pour frustrer des
futurs créances et ont par exemple
illustré le fisc
les caractéristiques du plan conçu par
kpmg aurait pu être utilisé à mauvais
escient par des fraudeurs selon mme
marois risquées ars et d'une opacité
parfaite loin des regards indiscrets et
s'éclate l'arrière qu'on peut pour
retracer le nom des véritables
véritables propriétaires véritables
accélère véritables bénéficiaires du
programme d'action du ring king james
l'ump dit voulait que kpmg fournissent
au comité les noms des riches canadiens
qui se cachait derrière les sociétés d'
île de man mais le président du comité
des finances le libéral wayne easter a
rejeté la motion
en fin de compte les noms des clients
canadiens et des sociétés écrans mis sur
pied à la demande n'ont jamais été
révélée
nous sommes rendus sur place à l'île de
man pour mener notre enquête sur ce
dossier lors de reportages précédents
nous avons trouvé des administrateurs
comme sandra joe jackson qui agissait à
titre de prête noms pour les sociétés
liées aux clients kpmg
mais nous avons fait face un mur de
silence
[Musique]
mais une fuite massive de documents
confidentiels sur les paradis fiscaux
nous a permis d'ouvrir une brèche dans
les secrets de l'île de man nous avons
eu accès à des courriels internes de
sandridge hodgson grâce au paradise
papers une fois obtenues par le
quotidien allemand süddeutsche zeitung
est partagée avec le consortium
international des journalistes d'
enquête et radio canada
dans une série des changes au sujet des
enquêtes menées par les autorités
fiscales canadiennes contre les clients
kpmg
sandra georgia sun dresse une liste des
sociétés écrans liés aux stratagèmes de
l'île de man la liste contient qatar six
axes spa taille chaque fois les quatre
compagnies qui ont pu servir à cacher
des fonds dans la sphère cinar brashear
des mendiants kpmg nous affirme
catégoriquement n'avoir aucun lien avec
ces quatre sociétés et soutient que
d'autres cabinets aurait pu copier leur
stratagème en consultant les documents
publics de l'île de man
kpmg déclare qu'il existe des
différences importantes entre les
sociétés qu'ils ont aidé à créer et ses
quatre compagnies le cabinet comptable
crois que sandra justin se tromper
qu'elle n'était impliquée qu'au niveau
administratif que ces déclarations sont
contradictoires et qu'elle offrait une
opinion et non pas un fait
marois risques et dit qu'il est possible
que ces sociétés n'a aucun lien avec le
stratagème de kpmg
mais elle estime que c'est peu probable
dans les courriels c'est clair le titre
ça vise les compagnies de kpmg dans un
litige fiscal avec revenu canada et la
liste comprend les quatre compagnies en
question aujourd'hui c'est le même
langage qui est utilisé
elles mêmes administrateurs et en plus
les mêmes personnes sont encore impliqué
dans ce dossier
elle croit que les pistes mises au jour
dans cette affaire devrait faire l'objet
d'une nouvelle enquête
aujourd'hui soulagés à céret ou vle
enquête à la lumière des nouveaux faits
de nouveaux documents ils ont matière à
réouvrir l'enquêté
qu'est-il advenu des principaux
instigateurs dans la sphère synarchie
augmente lui john's wood a qui
continuent de purger sa peine de prison
lino matteo lui a été à nouveau reconnu
coupable à l'issue d'un deuxième procès
intenté cette fois par l'autorité des
marchés financiers l' amf lui a imposé
une amende de 5 millions de dollars
maintenant en libération conditionnelle
et soutiens qui n'a pas les moyens de la
payer du feu gaap pour penser que j'ai 5
millions de dollars franchement votre
question est insultante mais pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas le système judiciaire
s'attend pas à ce que l'amant soient
payés et vous a été imposée pour envoyer
un message et quel est ce message dont
tu dont tu ne vous mettez pas ado la
haye mais c'est ça le message on arrête
ça arrêter les caméras apparemment
insulté par cette question
lino matteo exigent l'arrêt de
l'entrevue ok je m'en vais le terreau
dit qu'il est pauvre et la justice qui a
demandé jeudi l'aide juridique c'est
épouvantable qui avait pas d'argent qui
a pas pu travailler dans son domaine
qu'est ce qu'on a fait nous autres les
les vieilles personnes fallait
travailler l'argent je ne sais pas vous
mais
il ya de l'argent il attend et latin et
sa libération conditionnelle en 2017
après avoir passé un an et demi en
prison l'année dernière il a réclamé la
bcu la prestation canadienne d'urgence
pour les travailleurs touchés
directement par la kfw 19
une prestation à laquelle ils n'avaient
pas droit cette année sco c'est un ford
à méditer l'été dernier le magazine de
tourisme de luxe à vérone a publié un
texte signé par la conjointe de ron
howard burg
elle y dévoile que le groupe s'est rendu
au panama en 2005 pour une opportunité
d'affaires et qu'ils ont acheté une
propriété sur l'île de bocas del toro et
ils y ont construit sweet bocage un
luxueux centre de villégiature privées
qui accueillent dans la discrétion la
plus complète des multi millionnaires au
coût de 20 mille dollars américains par
semaine
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]